the queen's gambit is a best-selling
novel written in 1983 by walter tevis
it covers the life and times of an
orphan chess prodigy named beth harmon
as she rises through the ranks and deals
with a troubling past
and substance abuse issues it's a book
that was recently brought to the big
screen
if you will in an original netflix mini
series seven episodes to be exact
and i'm here to discuss all that it was
with the one and only good friend of
mine women's grand master jennifer
shahani
two-time u.s women's champion and author
of the book chess [__]
as well as with aaron hawaii who is
chess.com's esports producer a lot of
you know that so he's
kind of an expert on what we believe
chess entertainment should be
and he's also an amateur chess player
who's played in a few chess tournaments
himself hi
and all right how you guys feeling
great we're really excited to be here
like everybody's buzzing about this
netflix series queen's gambit so it's
fun to
get a chance to talk about it with you
guys well on the no the first question i
have is okay
we're talking about this mini-series i i
assume we've all had a chance to see at
least a few episodes right aaron how
many episodes have you seen at this
point
i think i've seen three so far so this
is great you'll be able to spoil it for
me
okay well that'll be great spoiler
alerts ahead right and jen you were just
saying you've seen all the episodes but
a couple of them you were distracted by
the end but
you you also read the book oh yeah and i
mean it was so grippy and the only
reason i was distracted i was
trying to rush through it for this and
my son you know sometimes
took me away but it was it was
incredibly ripping spoiler alert it was
so good
i'm not i'm not gonna tell we don't have
to give all the details away but it was
just very grippy it's easy
to binge well i want to start with you
jen and ask because you've read the book
how do you feel the adaptation was from
the book
to the netflix miniseries do you feel
they stayed true and all the elements
that were
that were appropriate to stay true to
what would be your thoughts quickly on
the book edit
adaptation itself you know i've read the
book a long time
ago when i was a kid inspired to be a
great chess player
so i remember um vaguely the book but
i am about to reread it because at us
chess women we're going to do this
this new book club about like books
related to either chats or like
intellectual growth
and that's our first book so i'm excited
to reread it but listen
the adaptation was so phenomenal that
it's hard to imagine
anything being much better so like the
book might be as good
i can't imagine it being much better
it's just it seems from like a
filmmaking perspective they
they nailed so many elements right well
to talk about the the actress that plays
the main character over to you aaron so
how what did you think of anya taylor
joy's
performance right we've seen her in
other things recently was in it was in
emma
but what were your thoughts on on her
performance overall and you feel she did
a good job from your perspective
um and maybe a little more new to the
chess community than me and jen as far
as
uh really really portraying what a chess
prodigy would be like
well definitely an aspect of one of the
earlier episodes that i
identified with uh was the experience
she had
going to her first tournament and just
being like what am i supposed to do with
this
where do i go right when do i press that
you know like i
had that experience myself at the um my
first tournament in the north american
open in vegas last year
um and and that's that's what it's like
but she
expressed a confidence that i definitely
did not have in my first tournament
um after getting all of that training
from the
the custodian that if you haven't seen
the series yet you'll meet in the first
episode
um but uh taking to it so much more
naturally and then showing that
confidence when she arrived
that i think is really important for a
show like this or a movie
like this where uh something
like chess is used as the premise that
brings all these people together is
i like to ask myself if it wasn't chess
if it was something else
uh would this story still be as strong
and i think the answer for this show is
definitely yes
obviously we love it because we also
love chess and that brought us there
um but the performances and the
photography and just
all of the other aspects of this show
make are so great that this could be
about something else
and it still has legs because of
things like that and obviously the
awesome casting that you mentioned right
well all right aaron talked a little bit
about the the first chest from
experience but jenna
you can speak more than anyone in this
call obviously about what it's like to
be a woman chess player obviously in the
chess community and what were your
thoughts on
on taylor joy's performance as far as uh
expressing i mean aaron says she had a
lot of confidence right and also
the experience of being a woman in a
very male dominated environment right
what were your thoughts on some of the
struggles she went through as a k in her
character and do you feel like
that adaptation as a real life woman
chess
prodigy player right which is who you
who you are and were how do you feel
like that came across and did you relate
with any of tho any of the feelings she
had and anything you would say about her
character sort of
growth throughout throughout the series
yeah
i mean i thought that
first of all i don't come into chess
movies or poker movies
like looking for um a completely
realistic portrayal
like i'm after getting into the spirit
of chess what makes us
love it and i think that she certainly
nailed that anya killer joy i've seen
some interviews with her talking about
her preparation for you know this role
and i frankly from what i've seen i
think she's a genius like i think she's
absolutely brilliant
and i think that's why she took this
world so well because obviously
she's portraying a brilliant um young
woman
um and yeah she you know she has some
gender specific like hurdles like you
know
getting her first period at a chess
tournament and things like that spoiler
alert oh my god
i gave away a keyboard you gave away the
whole movie no i'm kidding
seriously um she on the other hand she's
so strong
it almost feels like an asset because it
makes her
i'm so separate from everyone else she
stands out
and her brilliance stands out and i
think that
she kind of uses it to her advantage in
a way
as she feels special and she is special
right
um and she doesn't really play any other
women in the movie that
there's one right in the very beginning
yeah the first one she beats yeah
and even like the people she plays blitz
with like the simul
so if you count it there might be like
50 people she's played chess with in the
movie
i mean i didn't count but i would say
maybe 50 to 60. so she plays one woman
and 50 to 60 men and if the movie has
any flaw from like uh i would say like
to me like a
conceptual point of view because i think
it was almost perfectly done as a piece
of art
um from a concept point of view like if
you want to think of it as like a
feminist film and
i mean you don't have to but if you want
to think of it as feminist series it
certainly works in that way
in a certain way because it's this like
brilliant young woman who's also
interested in fashion and a free spirit
but the fact that other women it's kind
of like her at the very top
so she's a genius right which is a
character that's usually occupied by a
male
she's like the mad woman genius right
right um and then there's all the men
underneath that who are like smart of
different levels of intelligence
and then there's underneath that other
women right right
and like that that is not might come off
as a harsher criticism than it sounds
because
it also was set in the 60s right right i
think so
it's like it's not like they're saying
these women are dumb it's just that none
of them have any interest in chess and
the ones that do have an in-person chest
aren't good enough to play
even the people that she crashes right
so
being like a big promoter of girls and
women in chats that was like the one
thing like you know this pop song most
girls
right it's like is is beth an example
that any woman
can do anything or that there might be
some women out there that are
exceptional
and are actually even better at men at
the types of things men do
yeah it's a lot of food for thought and
i agree with your uh your breakdown of
the the different messages i guess you
could take
from it depending on what your
perspective is but giving the
perspective of chess players i want to
ask both of you
i think that was one of the most
interesting things for me but i'll start
with you aaron
as a as a less experienced chess player
right but
what did you think of the chess
adaptation itself right there the scenes
of the chess
uh what what did they what did they
speak to you in regards to how realistic
they were and
and uh and then i'll ask the same
question to jen in terms of how much you
enjoyed that
well one of my favorite moments uh
concentrating specifically on the chess
in the show
was uh i think maybe in the third
episode
where she's asked to think back on a
previous game that she played
and so she goes to sit down to a board
and begins to set up a position
from memory uh with the pieces before i
started really trying to learn chess
if somebody else did that in front of me
i was just kind of blown away like
how could you remember a position like
that and just set it up
just from memory like without diagrams
or whatever
what's funny is that um once i started
to take take chess more seriously
and prepare to play in tournaments for
the first time
i found myself myself able to do that
able to recall
clusters of positions and games that i
had just played to set it back up and
try to think about it again
like in ways that that i would have been
amazed by
in the past and then i became the person
other people were like wait you can do
that
you can remember what happened in that
game um
and and so i think not just like the
accuracy of specific
sequences that were shown in the film as
you know whether or not they're accurate
chess but more of like
i appreciated the accuracy of what
that's all
like the awe of being able to be so
focused on your chess learning
that the the culture that kind of exists
around people like that
uh setting up games and talking about
them with your opponents afterwards
or or just challenging each other to
rethink things
um they definitely captured that right
jim what were your thoughts on i guess
both the the chess x's and o's right
appreciating and
maybe what was the first chess position
you recognized that was famous um and
and your thoughts on what are instead
about
did they really capture what the feeling
is for you as a as a professional and
two-time us women's champion well
um i thought that bruce pandelfini and
gary kasparov as chronicled in the new
york times
did a really fantastic job with the the
chest scenes and like
the chest positions um i
agree with rn that it was also about
like the spirit
of it like the way she gets so excited
when she learns a new opening
from the custodian or you know she hears
about the sicilian
like that was very striking to me how
well they did that and i thought she
also did a really good job
with the blitz chest because that's
extremely difficult to do for an
actor and what interests me is that in
interviews i discovered that
she has a background as like a model and
an actress i mean and sorry
obviously she's an actress as a dancer
so she mentioned that the choreography
of dancing really helped her with being
able to like
you know the choreography of your hands
and like making these chest moves
quickly
um and you know particularly like where
she gets a blitz simultaneously like
this party where everybody's drinking
and she does a little time all
right um and she said that that she was
incredibly proud of herself for pulling
that off
and i actually did an art project once
with a
dancer friend of mine gabrielle revlock
we did something called hulicha
where were you hula hoop you see my hoop
in the background and played chess at
the same time
and i had to teach her how to play chess
so that she looked like a chess player
but it was a memorized game
um and she also did way way better than
like most people
and i think it's that that dancer's
training that you're looking for these
microscopic movements in the hands that
other people might not see
and like in the whole body and the
elbows
um and she i thought really
hooked me with her bliss performances
well and i'll say i observed that i i
actually think that
and i don't know if this is factual in
terms of how they filmed that i felt
like she
got even better as it went on which also
represented her character there is some
unsureness at first with the hands as a
chess player when they're learning but i
feel like as it went on
you could see the confidence and
something that i always look for
whenever i'm watching chess
uh shows in terms of the confidence in
which you watch a video with carlson
and nakamura and they move with no
hesitation right and you can see the
difference between players that do that
versus some unsureness right and i think
that everybody in their role
did a pretty good job with that for sure
and i just noticed that the white square
was always on the right right so they
they never messed up the chess the chess
was beyond and i would say it's probably
the best chess i've seen in any anything
on film since uh since the searching for
bobby fischer
movie and on that note i have to ask was
beth harmon supposed to be bobby fisher
is that who the character is based on
what did you what did you guys take from
that
or in first um i don't know if it was
necessarily meant to represent
somebody uh who is an actual you know
person
other than maybe the author because i i
think i read somewhere that
the author of the book actually had a
similar sort of experience in youth
with drug addiction that was forced upon
him or something like that but
um i think maybe she's an amalgamation
of different people not just in the
history of chess
but just in the history of excelling at
something to the point of
of becoming famous from it and right and
the pressures
that come from that the inner struggle
that comes from that
um sometimes the inability to
to listen to the input of others right
who are outside of that but
seeing you go through something right uh
i think that's pretty common among these
types of
of people in real life and so the all of
that
ends up being distilled into this one
character yeah jen your thoughts on that
um yeah i think that there's definitely
some references to bobby fischer
in the movie but there i agree
completely with um aaron that it's like
some kind of composite
you know there you see i think there was
some suggestion that there were some
gary kasparov
references in her character i got some
judah polgar even honestly
judith diana lanny actually who um
apparently
in some of the same circles as walter
kevis she just
wrote in my my wall in a post about this
that um she heard that
there were some references to her
because she did struggle with some some
of the same things that bec did in the
movie
and so i think uh yeah
that it was an incredible character but
i don't think it was like based on one
person
i did notice in your notes you had a
specific thought about judith polgar
that
perhaps the the hair color was a
reference right was it was a direct
homage i
i didn't know right just because i i
haven't read the book right so i wasn't
sure if the hair color was a direct
reference to the red the red hair
of jennifer jihadi that's that it was me
it was you i did see an interview with
her talking about that danny so i can
clear it up the
hair was brown in the book and the red
hair in the movie was her right or
the series rather was her idea to make
her stand out
from all the other characters
i mean not that being a a beautiful
woman was not enough because
all men but also nobody else in the
movie had red hair
so it's like that second layer of like
wow
she totally panned out but yeah of
course you can't help when you're
watching
it to think about judith pogar is like
flaming red hair
and like what it represents speaking of
standing out was the cowboy hat too much
i mean aaron okay i think the guy's
wearing a hat that might be a little too
much orange go ahead
cowboy hat too much i think there need
to be more hats and chests
okay there you go well you're referring
it what did you think
i felt like there was a little bit of an
eccentric nod to that to the eccentric
chess-obsessed guy right and
and as something maybe the cowboy had
for the writing kind of brought that out
but what was your thought on the outfit
that uh
that benny watts sported throughout the
entire series
i liked it i think the movie was
fantastic and moody and i liked that
benny represented like a little bit of
injection of humor
like he was like the one character that
was just kind of like pop
you know like earth little here's a
little humor and i actually wish the
movie had a tiny bit more of that
right so whenever he came on screen i
was like yeah because then we see the
contrast of her
moody emotive acting and like just
you know almost like kind of similar to
the drugs she's taking right right kind
of slows you down and then this
guy who's like not as talented as her
but a little bit more manic
right right large larger than life
character i definitely related to the
sleeping on someone's floor in new york
and having to like grab some
i mean i think a lot of chess players
have been there um well
all right i got i got a lot more
questions we can get to and one of the
things i wondered is we're all talking
about this as
chess players me and eugene especially
and arin you're
you're you're a chess professional in a
lot of ways now right but did you
did you watch with uh with your wife any
non-chess players with you and what were
their thoughts on it did you have that
experience
you know she actually made fun of me
when i
queued it up for the first episode you
just want to watch it because it's about
chess
but uh now she's like she's so hooked on
it because it's just an excellent
show regardless of the chess and so um
yeah i mean what was the original
question
what did she think about it so she you
answered it she was hooked on it she
liked it
even as a non-chess player and your your
husband daniel
is not a chess player either right jen
no and he actually works in film so he
had a lot of um
a lot of interesting thoughts on it um
yeah he he loved it he also binge it but
he loves chass
so it's not and we did like some chess
projects together
so it's not that surprising that he
really liked it but
yeah he talked about it also about this
like it's almost like
the show is a male fantasy in a way
because it's
you know it's about this female heroine
and it's it works both ways it works as
like
a a woman fantasy and it's a male
fantasy just like in a different way
just like the wanting to be with her and
the wanting to be her right those
different angles
and i yeah i really
i think that um the one thing is i'm
getting tons of messages
because i'm like a redheaded chess
player who wrote chess [__] right so
clearly there's like a lot of even
though i wasn't i wasn't
um around when he wrote queen's gambit
there was no me
in that i still like i'm getting
questions from people what do you think
of it do you like it were you involved
at all
right and so i and these are people that
don't play chess at all
um just you know friends from from high
school college
poker all over the place and invariably
people are like i love it
well we know that there were a couple
chess players involved you mentioned
gary kasparov and of course bruce
pandolfini and
pandorfini himself makes a cameo in
episode six were there any other chess
cameos that i missed
asking for a friend did anyone else see
any other chess gamers or was it just
pandelfini
i think it was just him because it was
shot in berlin
um yeah it was shot in berlin so there
there would be it would have to be it
has to be like a german chess player
maybe we don't
maybe we wouldn't recognize them got it
okay
sorry i just was curious if anyone else
saw um we've got uh
so one of the one of the questions we
got to ask first is your favorite scene
so far
well i really enjoyed um
both when she learned how to play chess
from the custodian i thought he was like
such a
magical character because it takes this
kind of
understanding of chess as something
that's totally not hierarchical so
they're playing chess in the basement
with somebody
in a job that's usually not as respected
as it should be although now
with like kobe 19 we understand very
much that
essential workers and keeping places
like clean is like basically one of the
most important things fundamentally
in society right so yeah we i think
we're getting that a bit more but in the
movie it's like
it's amazing how quickly chass teaches
you that
because you never once think of the
custodian as somebody who's like lesser
right never even though he's in the
basement and because of like the
lighting
they also make the basement look like
this magical place not like this dark
and damp place right
so from the very beginning the movie
just shows you like
this is the most beautiful place in
in the world right it's her favorite
place for sure you get you get that
sense from the character and i think
that
you know having played chess my whole
life that's one of the best parts about
it right it transcends age
gender race religion right like you said
a transition it
i always say that but it also transcends
hierarchical
sort of stereotypes and culture and if
anything
the custodian is sort of a god-like
almost father figure who's one of the
first nourishers she has right in some
ways
he sort of helps sort of take care of
her but um anyway yeah that's a great
point
i would ask on that note we've touched
on some of the
non-chess controversial topics orange
just said one of his favorite scenes
directly relates to maybe
something forbidden makes me wonder how
what age do you think is appropriate
for us to show this to young chess
players if we're looking for
uh something to inspire them a new chess
prodigy story
what age would you say it's appropriate
for someone to see it aaron
well uh being the parent of zero
children
i uh i don't know if my opinion will
actually be accurate but
i mean there's definitely some things
that um that
would probably hinder
the kind of like positive messaging
that you might want to try to impart on
your children by asking having them
watch the show with you
um so maybe they need to be i don't know
like
getting close to high school age um but
but yeah i think i think it could be a
good
story as long as you you know can get
past those things and just
and and show it to a child that you
think is at the right age to understand
the real messages
right right overall you know message
behind this story rather than just
focusing on
the individual moments because i think
that's what really shines about this
right is is not just like
the individual moments but like just
saying like
this is this can be what it's like to
have to like grow up and take care of
yourself and like try new things and
and and and maybe just like uh
not worry too much if you stand out
because you're different or you're
interesting or
whatever right that that that's not
always a negative thing i think there's
some good messages there yeah
good position oh there's lots of great
messages but it's a really wonderful
question
danny and it's something that i grapple
with is like the program director
of us chess women because i
um see that to me the question is not
you know what age is appropriate for
them to watch it but
they're gonna watch it you know so many
teenagers and free teams are gonna find
a way to watch this
and then how do we deal with the fact
that it has like such an empowering
message in one hand
but then also let's just be honest with
let's not fake it
or any incredibly unrealistic um
wrong message about what tranquilizers
or pills can do for your chest skill
right right there is no way that downers
are gonna help you protip everybody
that's not going to help you with chess
go ahead
that is not going to make you a test
genius it's not going to unlock your
genius
that is completely crazy and of course
the show needs to
introduce conflict and drama so it's
understandable why they made that choice
to go in that direction but alcohol and
downers seem like
it would really be like the worst thing
for your child right um
and particularly now when we have like
opioid epidemics with
you know fentanyl like people just
dropping dead because they
take you know a pill it's like i'm not
going to be the one
to give you the revelation that drugs
are bad right right
but it's like it's particularly with
pills right now and hopefully this will
start to change in like
the next few years you know i i'm really
praying because
you know i've lost people because of
bill's i'm sure
most many people watching this have um
it's
it's unfortunate to me but i think that
the reality is kids are super smart
so you got to be honest with them and
explain to them that like
this is a beautiful series but that part
is fictional
right that that kind of drug is not
going to unlock your genius
right well and maybe maybe definitely
make it to the end
right where you know you learned that
not every uh drug story has to be a
tragedy of
of succumbing but maybe one of triumph
and overcoming right and
against spoiler alert if if you're if
you were looking for a horrible ending i
think the ending is actually amazing
on that note i think before we end this
we have to ask so
where does this rank right it's a it's a
great series it's an adaptation but also
i i always think of the
the best chess films of all time before
i tell you where i would rank it
and maybe what kind of stars i would
give it i'll ask the two of you where
would you rank it among your favorite
chess film film
film experiences of all time
number one put it personally at number
one oh really because for me
um even though it does strive and i
think achieve
a level of accuracy in terms of like
the actual chess that's shown in it
but it does that
and tells an excellent story outside of
it
whereas all of the other chess you know
themed movies and television shows that
i've watched
um it's usually either you get one or
the other you get a lot of accurate
chess being shown
but not a lot of engaging storytelling
um
or just high quality production value
which is something i focus on
or you get it the other way around right
it's very entertaining
and very inaccurate very well this one
was just such a good
mix of both so i feel like i put it at
the top okay
jen what about you yeah i
i have to say uh orange stole my ranking
in that i think i put it at number one
too um because
of it i think it's a it's an unreal
achievement
it's it's hard to imagine a depiction of
chess
being um this beautifully executed and i
think a lot of credit must go to the
acting and the director for
that they really seem to just like allow
it to rise above
anything that i could have hoped for
that said it was seven hours long
so i think it's a bit of a apples and
orange comparison
i loved queen of catway i thought that
movie was brilliant as well i loved
brooklyn castle
so um i thought that for what its genre
was
it was close to 10 out of 10. um and
some of those other movies i think were
close to 10 out of 10
too but they were shorter so it's you
know i'd rather have seven hours of 10
out of 10 right than like
two hours of 10 out of 10. i you know as
you talk about i guess i'm maybe
surprisingly agreeing i think searching
for bobby fischer
to me at least previously to this one
took the cake of they got the chest
right
right and i think that one of the things
you know regardless of the true story of
josh waitskin and
uh and and his relationship with bruce
pandelfini whether that was
close to real or not didn't matter the
movie itself with lawrence fishburne the
scenes in washington square park the
scenes of
of the struggle of a young chessboard i
thought that was previous to this maybe
the closest
this is a little more adult than that
but i would agree that
because it's an apples to oranges
comparison seven hours of this is uh
i kept waiting for them to slip up and
they never quite did so i i think your
your ranking of 10 out of 10 agrees with
most of the people right now raking it
on rotten tomatoes and
and with that we'll encourage everybody
that they should definitely check it out
and make sure you see the queen's gambit
right now on netflix and uh if you don't
mind give us
give us your opinions and comments down
below let us know whether you agree with
some of our answers or or think we're
nuts
we love it either way and while you're
here give us a like and a share
and let us know what your what your
favorite scene from the queen's gambit
was so
thank you so much for uh for checking
out our breakdown of the queen's gambit
on netflix and uh
see you around on chess.com bye guys